have to ask you have you heard of the
other big news with the career change
that Lawrence Trent is about to have
with the chess boxing yes yes yes I did
I so uh what some people don't know is
that
um I was originally going to be the main
event for that fight uh not originally
going to be the main event but there
were talks of it being myself and Eric
Rosen and were evenly matched in chess
we're evenly matched uh probably like in
physical shape uh and what I what I we
But Eric and I were just having
conversations behind the scenes but it
wasn't going to work out logistically
like both of us would have had to commit
way too much time resources we also are
worried about head trauma uh which if
listen God bless those guys you know
they seem they seem like they know uh
what they're getting themselves into and
Eric also travels the world he's like
not interested necessarily in just
dropping his whole life and training but
I've I've been going to the boxing gym
I've been enjoying it a lot and if I
have a good opponent you know for the
next next event
um I will I will do it I'm very curious
to hear Peter's thoughts actually on
chess boxing let's bring him on
him in that event Peter himself is a bit
of a boxer uh Peter uh are you are you
excited did you see Lawrence's video the
trash talking has started
yeah hello Tanya Hello Larry hello
everyone no I haven't seen it yet uh
definitely we'll check it out uh
Lawrence in the ring I mean but talking
about Chess boxing I think it's very
important to understand that if chess
player faces chess player then I think
it's fine but I I wouldn't dare to you
know be be challenged by someone else
yeah I've seen us I've seen a thread who
would win Magnus or Mike Tyson and I
just don't even understand what's the
point of entertaining this because Mike
will sit there and make three moves and
he will get up and the fight will be
over he doesn't even have to throw a
punch so
um yeah chess player versus That's Where
It's tricky because they have to be
evenly matched at the chest and the and
the boxing so I guess Lawrence and the
man are gonna train and there'll be
newbies but they'll be uh pretty uh
they'll evenly matched on the chest side